and I've been looking for this
all my life Andy's back and fingers
crossed and we get one more giant
boulder scene it's hard to believe it's
been 42 years since Harrison Ford first
picked up a whip and a brown Fedora and
launched an action franchise and yes
we're all old now but this marks the
fifth and supposedly final film with
Ford in the leading role retiring well
in that case what are we drinking so we
are going to take a look at what to
expect for this final offering here's
everything you need to know before you
go see Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny
dad told me you found something
on a train during a war a dial that
could change the course of history now
of course we gotta go back and look at
Indy's previous Crusades so grab your
leather jackets and let's do this
the first Indie flick to Grace our
eyeballs was Raiders of the Lost Ark in
1981. our Boy George Lucas actually came
up with the idea after he finished
American Graffiti in 1973. I mean can
you say overachiever and sidebar Ford
was a real babe in that one too this was
the most perfect dazzling creature I've
ever seen now a few years later after
Lucas teamed up with some key players
like producer Philip Kaufman
screenwriter Lawrence kazdan and
director Steven Spielberg what was once
called The Adventures of Indiana Smith
was often rolling only now the title was
different and it was about Indiana Jones
instead that definitely has a better
ring to it the OG actors reportedly
considered for the lead were get this
Bill Murray Nick Nolte Jeff Bridges and
Tom Selleck before Harrison Ford was
cast having already worked with Lucas on
a couple of space flicks I'm in it for
the money and now I'm just picturing
Indiana Jones with that prominent Tom
Selleck mustache anyways in Raiders Ford
plays a renowned archaeologist who is
hired by the US government to find the
Ark of the Covenant which is believed to
still hold the Ten Commandments now
unfortunately Hitler has also sent men
after the same treasure but don't fret
because all of those baddies faces melt
off and let's just say it's a fun watch
this film actually has the highest
Tomato Meter and audience scores in the
franchise and it's the only one to
receive an Oscar nomination for best
picture and it also went on to become
highest grossing film of 1981 beating
out Superman 2. sorry Khalil you
poisonous snake I hate snake suck I hate
him now Indiana Jones in the Temple of
Doom may be the second film in the
franchise but Lucas made it a prequel to
Raiders of the Lost Ark to avoid having
Nazis as the villain again so this one
is actually set a year or so before the
events in Raiders and it finds Indy
teaming up with a nightclub singer and a
12 year old boy who we all know and love
to recover a precious gem and several
kidnapped Boys on behalf of a remote
East Indian village
now not only is this film responsible
for a rather buff Harrison Ford who by
the way did a strict exercise regimen to
gain a more muscular tone this was the
most perfect dazzling but it also
changed the movie rating system as we
know it because after complaints from
the MPAA about violence Steven Spielberg
suggested they alter their rating system
leading to a new PG-13 rating not to
mention scores and scores of angry 12
year olds now Temple of Doom actually
did win an Oscar for best visual effects
and it's also responsible for Spielberg
meeting his future wife actress Kate
cabshaw on set I mean a Miku in the
middle of a temple of doom who knew
no it's time for love we got company now
next up is 1989's Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade Steven Spielberg returned
to direct and said that it was his
favorite in the franchise this time
around Indiana embarks on a search for
Holy Grail and in the process stumbles
upon another archaeologist who had
disappeared trying the same thing turns
out that guy is Indy's Daddy be played
by a daddy himself Sean Connery Sean
Connery is my James Bond the most
perfect now another a-lister that made
it into the film that we all knew and
loved was River Phoenix who opens up the
film as young Indie in a fun origin
Story prologue the certified fresh film
which may have benefited from the fact
that Temple of Doom was deemed too dark
was the highest grossing movie of 1989
and won an Oscar for best sound effects
editing and I gotta say critics loved it
for its pacing suspense themes and big
stars naturally not
[Music]
course that brings us to oh boy here we
go the fourth one
2008's Indiana Jones and the kingdom of
the Crystal Skull which happened to be
released and takes place 19 years after
Last Crusade Now set in 1957 Indy goes
up against Soviet KGB agents led by Kate
Blanchett while searching for a
telepathic Crystal Skull yeah it's a
thing that's enough
enough now this time Jones is joined by
his former lover Karen Allen's Marion
Ravenwood along with their son mutt
played by Shia LaBeouf it was actually
the short-lived ABC series The Young
Indiana Jones Chronicles from the early
90s that helped make this one happen
after Ford narrated one episode about
events spanning into the 1950s Lucas
realized there were more stories to be
told about an older Indie and I guess he
was right because Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull became the fourth certified fresh
movie in the franchise surprising many
die-hard Indie fans because they didn't
like it but no pressure dial of Destiny
drop dead
foreign
that brings us to this latest Adventure
in the life of Dr Jones who as you know
is once again played by the one and only
Harrison Ford but and this is a big butt
this is the first and only film in the
series not directed by Steven Spielberg
and which doesn't have a story written
by George Lucas they're both credited as
executive producers instead will that
make a difference you tell me after
you've seen it but they didn't just get
somebody off the street to direct they
hired James Mangold who's best known for
hit films like Walk the Line Logan and
Ford vs Ferrari dudes legit now Mangold
also co-wrote the film along with
brothers jez and John Henry Butterworth
and David cope the latter of which also
helped write the previous Indie flick
among many other Spielberg projects now
on the other side of the camera along
with Ford will be John Reese Davis and
Karen Allen reprising their roles as
Salah and Marion Ravenwood respectively
from earlier films and joining them are
franchise newcomers Phoebe Waller bridge
is Indy's goddaughter Antonio Banderas
as an old friend of Indies and mads
Migos in as the bad guy a former Nazi
who works for NASA cannot wait for this
seat belts there might be some templates
now as far as what Indiana has up his
leather jacket sleeve for this final
installment supposedly we know that it
takes place in 1969 and he's joined by
his goddaughter in a Race Against Time
to recover a legendary dial that can
change the course of history no big deal
but also like one can accomplish many
things in a leather jacket of course
he's not the only one who's after it it
appears that Mickelson's character and
indy have some history dating back a
couple decades and now Mickelson and his
main henchmen played by Boyd hallbrook
are among the obstacles in Indy's way
and perhaps one more giant boulder for
old time's sake is it just me that
really wants Boulder to happen
friends this brings us to the end of not
only this episode but also of the man
himself Indiana Jones
now there were 19 years and 15 years
respectively between the past two
installments which always gives us a
reason to hold out hope but you gotta
think that Harrison Ford doing action
roles may be coming to an end I mean
he's still pretty badass in the show
1923 and is absolutely hilarious in the
show shrinking if you haven't seen it
yet and I gotta say I'm sure many exacts
have begged and pleaded and plotted to
potentially re-casserole with a hot
young name to keep things going but Ford
actually did say back in 2019 that this
is something he never wants to see
saying quote when he's gone I'm gone
it's easy and the last thing I'll let
you know before going into the theaters
is no major tears should be shed as
fieldwork has previously confirmed that
the character won't be killed off in
this final installment not saying that
leaves the door open for more movies but
not saying it doesn't am I right all
right you're probably more confused now
but that is everything you need to know
before you go see Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny in theaters June 30th my
name is as Perez I'm still wearing my
leather jacket and thanks for watching
and be sure to rate and review this film
at rottentomatoes.com
foreign